críticos de cuando hay máximos cuando
hay mínimos y cuando hay puntos de
inflexión así que esto es lo que voy a
hacer en este vídeo estos problemas que
vamos a hacer me los mandó a alguien que
pues la verdad no sé dónde esté pero son
algunos problemas bien interesantes
según yo no lo sé resuelto en vídeos
anteriores así que voy a hacer
exactamente los problemas como me los
mandó el primer problema dice encuentra
los puntos críticos de la función
identifica los máximos y los mínimos en
el intervalo dado la función que nos dan
es efe de x
es igual a x al cuadrado más 4 x 4 y el
intervalo que nos dan es de menos 4
observa que aquí puse corchetes lo cual
quiere decir que incluimos el menos 4 a
0 ahora nada más como nota lateral si
este intervalo lo hubiéramos puesto como
menos 40 en paréntesis entonces quería
decir todos los números excepto los
extremos acá quiere decir que si como
tenemos corchetes incluimos al menos 4 y
al 0 lo de acá es un intervalo abierto
que voy a tachar porque no es el del
problema pero va entonces la primera
cosa que nos piden es encontrar los
puntos críticos diferentes personas usan
diferentes definiciones pero la mía es
los puntos críticos son los puntos
interesantes es decir son los puntos
donde la derivada se anula o donde la
derivada no existe vale entonces en este
intervalo tenemos que derivar verdad
efe prima de x es igual a 2 x + 4
vale entonces cuando éste es igual a 0
apes 2 x + 4 es igual a 0 pasa cuando 2x
es igual
4 4 más bien ahí casi me equivoco cuando
x es igual a menos 2 ok entonces cuando
x es igual a menos 2 cuando vale fm2 efe
de menos 2 o sea ya sabemos que f prima
de menos 2 es igual a cero que es justo
lo que encontramos ya tenemos que la
pendiente es cero pero qué pasa con efe
- dos pues es 4 menos 84 o sea que da 0
fm 2 es igual a cero ahora evaluamos la
función en los extremos
efe de menos 4 es igual a pues a ver
tenemos menos 4 al cuadrado es 16 y
luego menos 4 por 4 16 0 y luego hay que
sumar 4 entonces efe
4 es 4 ahora cuánto sf de cero efe de
cero es igual a 0 04 34 muy bien
entonces vamos a graficar la función
para ver cómo nos queda y después para
que podamos decir cuál es mínimo y
máximo y así entonces voy a pintar por
aquí el eje x
ahí está por acá está el eje
ok observa que deje los números
negativos pues pues un poco más visible
es verdad porque va a ser el intervalo
que nos interesa el intervalo que nos
interesa es desde x igual a menos 4 como
por aquí hasta x igual a 0
sale ahora entonces la primera cosa es
identificar los puntos críticos que ya
vimos que el único que existe es menos 2
entonces menos 2 queda pues justo en
medio de menos 4 y 0 eso está padre
verdad lo voy a poner por aquí fíjate
aquí tenemos que fede menos 4 y efe de 0
es 4 un poquito de la intuición de atrás
es que una parábola es simétrica
alrededor de su punto crítico y por eso
en menos 4 y 0 tenemos el mismo valor
pero bueno aquí voy a poner el menos 2
entonces aquí tenemos una pendiente cero
en cero tenemos que vale 4 y en menos 4
tenemos que vale 4 también entonces la
gráfica se vería algo de este estilo
lo voy a pintar con otro color la verdad
gráfica vendría por aquí sólo voy a
graficar aquí en el menos 40 sale nos
quedaría como una u
ahora ya dijimos que menos 12 es punto
crítico pero ahora queremos los puntos
máximos y mínimos el mínimo pues
claramente es aquí en menos 2 verdad
quieres podríamos usar pues algún
criterio de concavidad o algo así vamos
a hacerlo digo es como mucho más difícil
que lo que tenemos que hacer para este
problema pero pues no está de más
hacerlo a ver vamos a sacar la segunda
derivada
efe doble prima en x es igual a la
derivada de la derivada o sea es igual a
entonces en cualquier punto en el cual
intentes sacar la concavidad pues
tenemos que se doble prima es mayor que
0 entonces siempre es cóncava hacia
arriba ahora como la segunda derivada es
positiva tenemos que la derivada siempre
va aumentando y por tanto menos 2
realmente es un punto mínimo va aquí va
aumentando y aumenta y aumenta la
pendiente cada vez más ahora pues bueno
digo ya hicimos esto que estaba como que
un poco más difícil para este problema
pero está bueno para aprender a utilizar
estos criterios
ahora vamos a los máximos
-4 y este en x igual a 0
ambos son máximos al parecer como que
empatan por primer lugar entonces ya
conseguimos nuestros puntos máximos x
igual a 0 y x igual a 4 o bien 04 y
menos 44 listo terminamos con este
problema vamos al siguiente sabes lo que
me pasa con estos problemas es que
entender la redacción y la terminología
que ponen y así usualmente es más
difícil que el problema bueno sigamos
aquí nos dicen que hdr es igual a 1
entre r va el intervalo que les interesa
es a chin ya se me perdió donde lo dejé
a claro aquí está es el intervalo que va
acuérdate de ese intervalo cerrado de
menos 13 en corchetes incluyendo los
extremos va entonces cuáles son los
puntos críticos pues ya se había dicho
que son los puntos en donde número uno
pues la derivada se hace cero verdad es
ósea y son los puntos fácil hitos o bien
donde la derivada no existe pero aquí va
a pasar algo interesante
porque pues vamos a ver en un ratito que
hay un punto en donde la derivada no
existe pero la función tampoco existe
entonces eso de ahí no va a ser un punto
crítico porque realmente no es
interesante déjame escribirlo por aquí
punto crítico entonces número uno es si
la derivada
es cero
pero 2 lo que te conté y bueno hace rato
no lo dije muy bien lo dije muy
informalmente la otra forma en la cual
podemos obtener un punto crítico es
cuando no hay derivada no hay de aysén
derivada pero fx está definida
ok entonces cómo vamos a ver en este
problema hay un punto en donde la
derivada no está definida pero fx pues
bueno más bien hdr tampoco está definida
entonces realmente no es un punto muy
interesante o bueno tal vez lo es no lo
sé a lo mejor tu maestro definió de
manera distinta punto crítico pero bueno
yo me aprendí que la derivada no tenía
que estar definida pero la función sí
bueno vamos a derivar h prima de r es
igual a pues esto es era la menos 1
entonces tenemos menos 1 por ea la menos
2 o bien menos uno entre re cuadrada va
esto de aquí es la derivada se podrá que
la derivada se anule pues no nunca va a
ser igual a cero pero donde no está
definida pues no está definida cuando
eres igual a cero verdad eres igual a
cero si puede pasar en ese intervalo
entonces h prima de 0 voy a escribir por
aquí qué
y ésta
definida pero h de 0 tampoco está
definida h de 0 le voy a poner aquí que
tampoco está definida pues porque no
podemos dividir entre 0 pero va entonces
en este caso no vamos a considerar que
tenemos un punto crítico como sólo nos
importa lo que está dentro del dominio
de la función entonces pues no podemos
decir gran cosa pasamos a hacer la
gráfica de esta función déjame a ver si
podemos hacer una gráfica más o menos
decente lo que nos gustaría hacer es
pues trazar algunos puntos verdad eso es
un buen truco cuando estamos atorados en
un problema podemos hacer una figura y
de ahí darnos una idea de cómo se
resuelve el problema en general entonces
vamos a poner el eje x más o menos por
aquí para tener espacio hacia la derecha
entonces queremos ir desde r igual a
este de aquí es el eje r verdad y este
de acá es el eje hdr ok entonces
queremos ir desde r igual a menos uno
como de por aquí
y hasta era igual a 3 digamos a este
punto de por acá vale hasta era igual a
ahora vamos a poner algunos puntos
cuánto es hd menos 1 pues es menos 1 es
este punto de acá
vale
ok y luego que sucede conforme nos vamos
acercando hacia 0 por la derecha osea si
nos vamos moviendo hacia la derecha más
bien entonces si eres menos un medio
estamos como que por acá en menos dos y
pues asintóticamente nos vamos yendo al
menos infinito algo de este estilo va lo
voy a pintar más o menos así
ok
estoy aquí podrías seguir dibujando lo
hacia abajo y hacia abajo pero se me
acabó el espacio ahora cuánto es h de 3
pues h de 13 es un tercio que está por
ahí y luego que va a suceder conforme
nos acercamos a cero bueno si ponemos un
valor muy muy chiquito aquí hdr se hace
muy muy grande y entonces de hecho lo
que sucede es que esta cosa
asintóticamente se va a más infinito
la gráfica quedaría más o menos así
siempre he tenido problemas dibujando
esta gráfica y así que si queda un poco
fea pues ni modo entonces se vería algo
este estilo se va a más infinito esta de
aquí abajo le voy a poner por aquí que
se va a menos infinito y bueno la verdad
tan solo con ver esta gráfica podemos
entender por qué uno entre r no está
definido en cero si nos acercamos por la
derecha se va a más infinito y por la
izquierda se va a menos infinito pero
peor aún ni siquiera podemos dividir
entre cero hay muchísimas razones para
que uno entre r no esté definida y de
modo similar tampoco vamos a poder
encontrar la derivada ahí para que se
hiciera la derivada necesitaríamos un
cierto límite que no vamos a poder
conseguir por ninguno de los dos lados
ok entonces cuáles son los máximos y los
mínimos déjame ver
pues o sea así a simple vista que sucede
a ver en este valor a lo mejor podríamos
pensar que es un mínimo bueno es un
mínimo local pero no es un mínimo máximo
porque aquí hay muchos valores más
chiquitos verdad entonces aquí se van a
menos infinito de modo similar este es
máximo pero solo local porque aquí hay
otros valores que se van a infinito
entonces realmente lo que acaba
sucediendo es que no existe ni un mínimo
global ni un máximo global porque bueno
pues diciendo lo de una manera informal
esto es porque en cero hay valores tan
cercanos a más infinito y a menos
infinito como querramos entonces no
podemos dar un número que acote a la
función mira por ejemplo aquí aunque nos
acercáramos mucho mucho a cero ya esto
le llamamos un máximo estaríamos
haciendo algo incorrecto pues tantito
más a la izquierda la función tiene un
valor más alto vale entonces en resumen
aquí no hay ningún punto en donde haya
un máximo global o un mínimo global eso
está interesante pero bueno ya se me
está acabando el tiempo ya me estoy
pasando de los 11 minutos y aunque
youtube ya me dio permiso de pasarme
pues creo que no está tan padre pues eso
hablando durante más de 10 minutos de
conocimiento entonces seguimos con esto
después